-Welcome back, guys.
It is time for
"Tonight Show #Hashtags".
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
This week,
I sent out the hashtag
"MyFamilyIsWeird".
And I asked you to tweet out
a funny, weird,
or embarrassing thing
a family member has done
or said.
Within minutes, within seconds,
it was a trending topic
in the U.S..
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wonder why.
Thank you all for playing along,
now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"#MyFamilyIsWeird" tweets
from you guys.
And there's some weird families
out there.
It's awesome.
This first one's
from @coveydenton, she says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Chuckles ] That's one way
to wake up the kids, yeah.
This next one's from @ckgirl04,
she says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wha--
Never heard of that.
-[ Deep voice ]
♪ Happy birthday ♪
♪ Happy birth... ♪
[ Light laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I think
it's fun.
This one's from @JurneesRainbow,
she says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Get out.
-Get outta here!
[ Applause continues ]
-Somebody gotta judge.
This one's from @MPetricoin,
she says...
[ Audience groans ]
-Whoa.
-Is this from my wife?
Yeah, I don't know.
I feel like my mom did that.
This one's from @rjt1605,
he says...
[ Applause ]
I'm so sorry.
I hope you're in therapy.
I'm sorry.
This one's from
@JakeWilliamsArt, he says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, pop me a Fro-Po, man.
[ Applause continues ]
[ Laughs ]
-Po-sicle.
-Pop my a Fro-Po, bro.
This one's from @OlMusky.
-Ooh.
-They say...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Dad needs his me time.
-Yeah, he needs his me time.
Shh!
-This one's from @Arshdhillonk
she says...
[ Audience groans ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
-Ouch.
How long did they have to get?
-This one is [Laughs] from
@kyledice23, he says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Nice job.
-That's nice.
-Good turn!
-This one's from @ReneeJordan78,
she says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
He choked on it.
You win!
-[ Imitates choking ]
-You won.
-This last one's from
@eddielovestoast, he says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those were our
"Tonight Show #Hashtags".
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.